in Thomas Pynchon's sprawling epic
postmodern novel gravity's rainbow
there's a sequence in which the main
character is interrogated by the US
government under the influence of sodium
amytal commonly called truth serum the
writing slips into several dreamlike
rips on language in one a telegram from
Wisconsin launches the main character
into an obsessive meditation on the
possible constructions of a six word
sequence you never did
the Kenosha kid as more and more
examples are presented each with
different punctuation
we become aware of a key postmodern
truth that words can point toward
reality but they can never get there
they always mean different things in
different contexts but just how many
different contexts are there well
Pynchon only gives us seven there are
far too many punctuation marks and
emphases far too many combinations for a
single writer to catalog them all
besides in the aesthetic universe of the
novel cataloging them all would be
exhaustive and redundant enter the
internet and a man named Darius Kazemi
hi everybody he makes what he likes to
call weird internet stuff I make what I
like to call weird internet stuff which
I've recently come to accept is internet
art last year Darius made a Twitter bot
that did what the writer Thomas Pynchon
can't ever do it automatically generates
a different construction of the you
never did the Kenosha kid sequence every
two hours as of this video the account
has already tweeted 86 hundred times and
with the number of permutations possible
could continue for years without
exhausting everyone go there sometime
try reading a few out loud the effect of
pyncheons language experiment is
compounded updated the truth that wants
to communicate is received in a new way
and the exhaustive 'no step in
appropriate
is made novel and strangely vital in
this new form I think what this shows us
is that the aesthetics of Internet art
art made with and for and on the
Internet won't conform to any that we've
known before and that's fitting because
a lot of internet art is made unlike any
art that came before it
because Amy's Twitter BOTS aren't made
with paintbrushes or musical instruments
they're made with algorithms with code
this is what the Kenosha Kidd Twitter
bot really looks like is there any
beauty in that what about this body no
it's just a set of instructions well
here's what those instructions do this
programming these rules perform a simple
task they access the Texas Department of
Criminal Justice and pull from the
public last word statements of death row
inmates any sentence that contains the
word love this art piece isn't out to
make an overtly political statement on
capital punishment like all good art
this project organizes elements in the
world around it to help an audience see
and feel in a new way the difference is
that the world cos Amy's commenting on
isn't the physical world not really
it's the digital world the world of the
Internet and indeed much of our digital
internet art is focused on itself on the
visible and more importantly invisible
aspects of a network that's all around
us computation is now everywhere it is
led of everything and we are living
inside that computer as well that's
James bridle a critic and digital artist
bridle did a project recently called
rainbow plains a project that started
when he noticed some odd artifacts from
Google Earth of planes with rainbow
after images it's a glitch but like all
true glitches it's not just a mistake
it's kind of an opportunity to look
through into the underlying systems that
produce this image in this case it shows
us that the satellites composing these
images aren't using camera
but rather are collecting data from a
broad swath of the electromagnetic
spectrum and they record red green and
blue separately when they when they make
these data images and so occasionally
you find within satellite images these
artifacts which are produced by fast
moving objects Bridals digital art wants
to help us see the way technology sees
us how hugely powerful systems have
moved slowly into our lives without much
protest these systems are not like us
we see with eyes they see with data we
think with minds they think with
algorithms art like this shows us that
our increasing dependence on
sophisticated technologies comes at the
cost of substituting our values and our
motives for theirs
so maybe the aesthetic value of Internet
art is measured by its ability to help
us see the Internet just as a novel can
help us see language or an image can
help us see reality that's just an idea
and I can't say how valid it is for you
but I think we do have to try to develop
an aesthetic for this new digital art a
way by which we can determine which of
it is good which of it is crap in which
we consider truly essential because what
we think is great art speaks ultimately
to what we think is valuable in culture
and articulating our values about the
Internet the global network in the years
before it consumes everything might just
be the most important thing our
generation could ever do
everybody thanks for watching getting
this in just before sunset here welcome
to 2016 you want to help me out in 2016
you can pledge a dollar or three dollars
per video by clicking right below here
and going to my patreon page that money
will go toward making 50 new videos for
you guys this year which is an exciting
prospect to make what I hope is content
unique to YouTube and the Internet so
thank you guys again I will see you all
next Wednesday